so uh let's get stuck back into it i
want you to remember
from our previous lesson we're having a
look at scenarios like this we're
looking at objects
particles bodies that were under
equilibrium they were equilibrius if you
remember me
mentioning that you know made-up
sounding word we're looking at
situations where
all the forces acting on a body like
this
are perfectly imbalanced and at the end
of the lesson i just made a very brief
mention of the fact that if for example
you know this this particular example
here it used to have
an extra force on it over here which
balanced it all out
if we were to take away such a force and
now things are not balanced anymore
then what we get here is this resultant
force because we do not end
back where we started we don't if we
pictured these vectors as representing
displacements
we don't come back to our origin as it
were
and so the difference between where we
started and where our quote unquote
displacement vectors take us
that's the result of all of our forces
so in fact one of the reasons why
it's a fairly common way to denote these
vectors
you'll often see this called r and i
like to think of it i don't know if this
is what they're intending
but i often like to think of that r as
meaning and force okay
so what we're going to do as mrs lee's
mentioned on tuesday
is we're going to push forward into what
happens when these forces
don't balance out right so here was
that second example and what i've done
is rather than removing one of the
forces
instead i've made one of the forces
larger so this is
this force going off in the you know
somewhat south easterly direction as it
were
and by the way you're going to hear
compass language
used a fair bit in some of these or
you're going to see it use the fair bit
and many of the questions that you
encounter
because um in order to describe what's
going on right rather than left or right
it's a little more
there's a bit more precision in language
like say southeast
then it's going down and to the right
now when you have a look at a scenario
like this what i want to emphasize for
you and
i'd love you to draw a version of this
on your page
maybe nearby to where you have that
previous equilibrium example
i want you to recognize the fact that
when we think of these force vectors
like displacement vectors because vector
addition
is commutative we can do it in any order
i could say well let's consider vector a
and then adding on vector
b and then adding on vector c i could i
could think about it in those terms
or i could do it in a different order i
just want to show you what that looks
like and how important it is for you to
get the sense of thinking geometrically
about this right
so if i did um vector a and then b
and then c just going clockwise around
what would that look like um and i want
you to take a moment just to do a
rough and dirty sketch of what that
would look like where you would end
after you did um a and then b and then c
do it on your page and just give you 10
seconds to kind of um do your own one
there
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to reveal it and then interpret
what we're looking at right
so i don't know if that was 10 seconds
i'll give you a little bit longer
um don't worry about marking any labels
around that kind of thing because
that'll take you too long
let's have a look at what you get if you
do a and then b and then c i think this
is kind of what you create right so our
a vector was
heading in the north direction and then
our b vector was the one i mentioned
that was going
sort of southeast it's not actually
going southeast because exactly
southeast would not be a 120 degree
angle
it would be a 135 degree angle
right so you've got this heading off in
this direction and then when you do
see after that and this is the important
part that i want to emphasize right
because if i go back to where c was
denoted right see this angle 120 degrees
on the left hand side it's measured from
the vertical
right so therefore i also have to
measure from the vertical
in this situation here so you got to
kind of put that vertical back in it
sort of disappeared
and this is very analogous to back in
like years 9 and 10
when you do questions to do with
bearings you would often have to put
north onto your diagram on multiple
different spots
to indicate um where that was actually
where your different bearings are being
measured from
right so you can see after doing a and
then b and then c
we end up over here so because we don't
return back to our starting position
in terms of forces what that means is
i've got this resultant force
and you can see by virtue of all of the
different angles here the resultant
force is heading off
at an angle of 120 degrees
clockwise from the vertical and it's
going to have a magnitude of
one which makes sense because you know
if i had drawn this back to where it was
before everything balances
and now i'm going an extra unit off in
that direction
okay now again i'm going to give you a
moment to think about how this would
look if you drew this
now yourself if i changed the order if i
pushed on this community
comm muted commutative communicativity
on the fact that it is commutative to
add these vectors together
what if you did b and then a if i swap
the order instead of a and then b
and then if we finished up with c can
you draw for me a rough diagram
of what this would look like and by the
way i actually shouldn't say roth
diagram
i did emphasize last time that drawing
reason as close as you can to scale is
going to be highly advantageous to you
when you were doing diagrams um for
bodies in equilibrium it didn't sort of
matter as much because you sort of knew
that you were going to come back to the
start but in these situations you're not
you're going to end up somewhere else
and
sometimes it's a matter of precision as
you're going to see in the examples
we'll look at later today as to whether
it looks like that or not so i hope that
gave you a moment to draw b and then a
and
c here's what my b and then a and then c
looks like right
i started from my origin i then did b
off in that
south east ish direction then goes a
and then i did c which is sort of going
in that southwest direction right
doing b and then a and then c clearly
has landed us on that same spot i'm
still doing the 120 degrees
it's even more obvious now that it's 120
degrees because
it directly comes from the direction
that b is headed in right
and so you can see all of the angles
making up this
equilateral triangle over here because
you've got this 1 1 1
relationship and we get the same
resultant
vector all right last one just for the
sake of it right
we've been doing c last in both of those
instances what happens if we do c
first go ahead draw where you will head
if you go to c
and then do a and b and let's see if you
end up
if your diagram can show where you
should end up i'll give you a minute
just to do that
oh you don't need a minute but maybe 10
seconds
okay so here let me reveal now what i
think it should look like
where have we gone first here's my
origin i went through c
and then a excuse me and then as i go
along b i pass back through the origin
because again i create this new
equilateral triangle here in fact i hope
you can see the symmetry
to the one over here why is it that i've
got this symmetry
from c plus a plus b well it is doing
b plus a plus c exactly backwards right
so can you see
that i've got actually um it's sort of
it looks to me like it's
rotational symmetry no it's reflectional
it's
yeah no sort of that's a bit of both
actually um
it's oh no i think i know i'm reflecting
across the wrong line it's not
horizontal it's reflected across the
origin right
of course it is because the origin is
where we're i'm starting around so
i hope you can see here the point and
that whichever way you go about this you
get something
that gives you the same net force the
same resultant force though i do wonder
as you have a look at all three of these
if you think any of these diagrams is
easier to interpret than any of the
others
the order that you do things as we've
seen before if you were say for example
as we go back to like say series and
sequences right if i gave you a sequence
of numbers
and i said can you please add these up
you could just do them
left to right or right to left but
there's going to be an order that's
actually going to be easier if you pair
up numbers
in a meaningful way you can say oh you
know i'm going to have
this blue pair which is 7 this green
pair which is 7 this uncolored pair
which is 7. so there's an order which
makes things easier
and we can do that with addition because
it's commutative so pick an order that
makes sense